douze exclusions jour se trouve sur
garde patch day c'est un jeu qu'on avait
testé il ya de cela un an il est sorti
en accès anticipé sur steam
le mode histoire d malheureusement pas
disponibles ça raconte l'histoire d'un
mec qui est bloqué dans une boucle
temporelle
voilà donc on se lève de bon matin et
peu importe la manière dont on va mourir
parce qu'on va crever vous le savez eh
ben on se réveillera nouveau et la
journée commencera ce qui est assez
horrible finalement un parcours commence
la journée qu'on est dans ces jolis
tajadod même le brave j'adore le style
graphique ça nos amis de faire du piano
bordel
ça c'était la bande-son interstellar
voilà sinon on fait juste du piano pour
toute la vie allez on va bouger alors on
peut aller 2-1 et on peut choisir d'être
vilain ou méchant ce qui est vraiment
génial par exemple l'ajout l'apport de
ce micro jeux la claque choix gangster
by milk il faut que j'achète du lait
alors on ira acheter du lait c'est noté
dans un petit coin de il faut acheter de
la nourriture ont surtout incertaine
chine tous devait certes ou pleine eau
alors c'est le cas c'était quoi
attention à la question et une parfaite
imposture alors on attend le mec à sanaa
devant chez lui personne ne dit rien on
peut soit être vilain et fait chier les
épreuves où on a besoin pour baic a
tourné armée dans ce village c'est
n'importe quoi vous savez pourquoi
pourquoi expliquez moi bordel au holà
aux gars mais vous c'est quoi c'est le
shérif en fait ça va je me demande non à
l'eva temps ça suffit
oh là là ni cale du coup maintenant je
suis probablement rechercher quelque
chose du genre non c'est un peu le le
gta d'human grave c'est joli même la
fumée j'adore le style graphique mon
gars c'est génial alors on va aller chez
cet homme bonjour au revoir aux c'est
sympa didot joli design a le mieux c'est
de mettre des meubles dans ta pièce dans
my quand même où à tout casser
c'est le même bruit que dans ceux
forrest quand tu coupe un arbre
j'aime beaucoup sa maison même si a que
deux pièges j'aime énormément je la
trouve très lumineuse très hachée pas
j'aime beaucoup c'est marrant squeeze
plaza il est là pour vous trouver un
nouvel appartement en fait j'ai
confiance ça je faisais arnaquer maison
suivante moi j'adore voir justement
comment le mac os abiker on peut être en
mode slow motion joue
sachez que je ne vous veux aucun [ __ ]
de mal chez un voisin je veux juste voir
nos maisons en fait j'adore la maison ce
qui a énormément de vie de voiliers
c'est très lumineux comme espace et à
lumières ce bien-être l aps
mais rentre chez toi tout simplement de
lui il est jumelé de péter ça parte
comme porto et qu'est ce qu'on a ici ou
ici je pense y ait des gens qui sont
pendus y avait des exercices et
apathique sébastien qu'elle composait
ses chansons elle sert d'endroit hanté
faut surtout pas y aller alors qu'est ce
qu'on a ici on a une centrale nucléaire
ici c'est des bureaux grâce et la st on
va boire alors montons là haut c'est
quoi s'attendre avec blocs portes mexes
n'a aucun sens y a rien dedans alors
dernier étage nous avons toujours yara
joue au basket ball avec cet homme
attend la tape la balle se plaît
sarat et gun shot c'est parfait bonjour
j'aimerais acheter des arbres à ce n'est
pas encore fait alors ils veulent de
l'aide mais ils sont pas trop paniquer
non plus quoi je veux des données il
faut que je commande je veux des
montagnes 2 to date et shooter d'honneur
comme ça voilà c'est ma passion je suis
parfaitement normal comme les gars
qu'est ce que c'est que ça tue les
cellules et mon gars [ __ ] je peux pas
le prendre je vais y annonce était notre
seule mission le seul but dont je tue la
casse et tu l'as brécey allons voir le
bar avec une hache bon c'est comme ça
corps dans un bar et qu'on veut imposer
le respect auquel on peut pas commander
un truc je te plaît ne tombât nuls ya
personne n'y avait pas de bois sourire
rien ses baguettes à coups de hache ça
la police va me tirer dessus a vu
apparemment que le vc-1 monde sont fiers
le plus loin possible
ou alors de tout ce blanc braquer une
banque hopla h à l'ancienne allez on
ramasse tout ça on est bien et baumes
3094 de là et c'est quoi ça c'est white
de la banque dans ses escaliers qui
mènent nulle part
merci beaucoup à ton avis trop pas
l'inde et la morgue intuitive europe
sans déconner aller au nom à l'esa et
c'est pas grave puisque la journée se
répète
non je suis carrément volé la voiture de
cet homme aux mondiaux au coût de lui -
pour aller au travail comme ça en
voiture pour toi mais plus tard il est
qu il se suicidait petit lait battu les
policiers bon on sait jamais donc je
vais quand même tous bois et bien vous
savez quoi on va se rendre dans cette
usine nucléaire
alors soit on se tape tous les étages à
pied seront pour l'ascenseur c'est même
plus drôle de se prendre l'escalier
lors du grand l'ascenseur [ __ ] qu'est
ce qu'a pris cette décision de merde
admirez la vue alors là mon gars que la
puissance de son crew soit en nous honda
télé sur lui ce serait incroyable regard
autant qu'on va pas mourir au nom des
morts pourquoi mais joli a explosé de
police s'il vous plaît qu'à cannes on
fait un exposé de ma maison
s'il vous plaît reculez
la cascade attend kroes alors oui le
petit lac au regard des on n'avait pas
vu ça une machine à broyer les gens il
faut conteste rien et lui parfait voilà
attend sur cette scène est interdit aux
moins de 18 ans s'te plaît rentrer là
dedans s'il te plaît tu peux faire les
forces te plaît de justes aux homos mais
purée
ouais
égoïste merde à la longue bédié pour se
décontracter un peu la [ __ ] et m'a tendu
le cou aux antibiotiques à quoi à temps
mais il peut rester dix secondes
toujours soit mourir quand-même satom
tâche est en train de péter un câble la
charte a pas de cet argent sont
j'aimerais qu'ils me réveille au haïku
peut faire péter la centrale nucléaire
et qu'une grenade
regardons et voilages ans la fin de
cette vidéo sur garbage personne la plus
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à aller mais
comme d'habitude moi j'ai adoré ce jeu
on y avait joué il ya vraiment pas mal
de moi et c'était beaucoup un beau
graphiquement là je trouve que ça a
vraiment un pur style c'est ça a
beaucoup de charme malheureusement il
manque cruellement de contenu mais c'est
le problème des jeux qui sortent en
action de 6 pc que souvent maille ier
ils n'ont pas anticipé quoi on en fera
peut-être au-dessus cohérent à plus de
contenu et puis merci devant rien pour
se retrouver dans une prochaine vidéo
portez vous bien sûr que mon fils